you were uh
a judge several times on the iron chef
how do you judge a good meal
like what uh your own other people's
like uh what rating system is good i
mean i go on experience and think about
how many of your like most memorable
fantastic meals are like three star
machine
meals it's more about the experience
right it's more about that slow down who
are you with
um and some of our best meals are like
the most simple things yeah
so iron chef you know those are those
were fun experiences
um it's a lot of sous-vide though it's a
lot of sauces
it's a lot of powders i mean it's kind
of like magic food yeah so
that's not i mean it's incredible to
watch it as science
um but i don't know if that's my most
memorable meals so
the experience is how you judge a good
meal for you personally if you were a
judge of the entirety of the human
experience
in terms of the the culinary journey
that would be like the people you're
eating with
the environment like how you feel
the journey building up to that meal
like the whole thing you can't separate
it out when i was
learning as an apprentice cheese maker
in greece
the one of the best meals my life is
like a bowl of cold
sheep milk yogurt with like a crust of
cold fat on top so like the way that
these
fatty you know sheep milk can have
double the percentage of fat than cow
milk
so like there's the yogurt and then
there's this crust of fat and then they
pour
the fresh honey over the top and you
just eat like this bowl of
probably top five meals of my life right
i mean
it just that's the simplicity is just
the best thing and it was the fact
that's in terra cotta and i had this
amazing day
and you know all these things come
together but i still remember that
feeling and i think
most of us have those like really great
sensual memories
of food and they're not about
necessarily
that one ex fancy over-the-top
restaurant or something it's really
about the whole context of enjoyment
you